MUERTOS
TREY: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, I AM TREY GOWDY, IS
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA."
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
SEEN CRIME SCENE PHOTOS FROM
A CRIME SCENE INVOLVING A
HAMMER IT IS GRUESOME.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA.
TO PAUL PELOSI, HUSBAND OF
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI, HE WAS
ATTACKED IN HIS HOME, SHE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ATTACKED HAD
SHE BEEN HOME ARE.
WE'RE TOLD MR. PELOSI WILL
RECOVER, PERHAPS PHYSICALLY,
CAN YOU RECOVER FULLY
RECOVER KNOWING SOMEONE HAS
SO LITTLE REGARD FOR YOUR
LIFE, THEY WOULD STRIKE YOU
IN THE HEAD WITH THE INTENTS
TO KILL USE A HAMMER?
BONES MAY MEND, BRUISES MAY
HEAL, YOU DON'T EVER FULLY
RECOVER WHO YOU COME
FACE-TO-FACE
WITH DEPRAVITY.
THE CHILDREN AND SPOUSES OF
FEDERAL JUDGES HAVE BEEN
SHOT IN THEIR HOMES, SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES HAVE BEEN
TARGETED FOR ASSASSINATION,
MOBS HAVE CHANTED, HANG A
VICE PRESIDENT,
PEOPLE ARE ACOSTED IN REST
RESTS AND LOBBIES OF THEIR
WORKPLACE, NOW AN ATTACK ON
A FAMILY MEMBER IN HIS HOME.
WITH OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF US, ONLY WEAPONS WE WOULD
USE IN POLITICAL
DISCOURSE ARE THE POWER OF
PERSUASION AND RIGHT TO
GROUP, BUT THERE IS A SMALL
GROUP, SO UNATTACHED TO
PRIAL REALITY.
WE SHOULD SAY FEWER CRAZY
THINGS.
AND HAVE A PLAN.
IT TAKES POLITICAL
COURAGE TO DEFEND FRIENDS,
BUT QUESTION IS DO WE HAVE
LITTLE BIT COURAGE
TO PHYSICALLY DEFEND THOSE
WITH WHOM WE DISAGREE.
EVEN BEFORE WE WERE A
COUNTRY.
HIS FRIENDS TOLD HIM NOT TO
DO IT IT WAS POLITICALLY
UNWISE, IT WOULD HURT HIS
CAREER.
HIS LAW PRACTICE AND
STANDING IN THE COMMUNITY,
THIS LAWYER DID IT ANYWAY,
BECAUSE AS HE TOLD THE JURY,
HE WOULD RATHER ENDURE
CONTEMPT OF ALL MANKIND THAN
SEE AN INNOCENT PERSON
CONVICTED OR AN INNOCENT
LIFE TAKEN.
HIS FRIENDS WERE WRONG, THAT
MAN JOHN ADAMS WOUND UP
BECOMING THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES, DESPITE THE
CAUTIONS OF HIS FRIENDS OR
MAYBE BECAUSE HE PRECEDED IN
THE FACE OF THOSE RISKS.
MAYBE THAT IS WHAT WE WANT
OUR LEADERS TO DO, THE RIGHT
THING NO MARRIED WHAT.
WHAT WILL WE DO 250 YEARS
LATER, TO KEEP OUR PERCEIVED
POLITICAL OPPONENTS FROM
BEING ATTACKED